Das ist wirklich ziemlich spektakulär: Zum
ersten Mal ist die Supraleitung bei Raumtemperatur
gelungen!
Das Ganze ist so etwas wie der heilige Gral
der Festkörperphysik.
Strom ohne Widerstand bei Raumtemperatur leiten.
Bislang schien das unmöglich - und das trotz
intensiver Forschung.
Doch einem US-Forschungsteam ist jetzt der
Durchbruch gelungen: Die Fachleute präsentieren
ein Material, das elektrischen Strom verlustfrei
leitet - und das ACHTUNG bei Raumtemperatur.
Dennoch gibt es einen Haken.
Clixoom Science & Future - hier gibt es drei
Mal pro Woche spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke
- nur so verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen! Das ist eine echte Premiere.
Denn es scheint so, als hätten US-Fachleute
nun ein jahrelanges Ziel der Physik erreicht.
Zum ersten Mal überhaupt ist es Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern nämlich gelungen, ein
Material zu entwickeln, das Strom nahezu ohne
Widerstand leitet - und das bei Raumtemperatur.
Darüber berichtet sogar das renommierte Fachmagazin
“Nature” als Titelgeschichte.Und dieser
Durchbruch ist wirklich spektakulär.
Denn es ist keine Übertreibung , wenn ich
sage: Supraleiter haben das Potential, die
Welt, wie wir sie kennen, zu revolutionieren.
Denn die Supraleitfähigkeit verhilft Materialien
zu zwei entscheidenden Eigenschaften.
Zum einen geht der elektrische Widerstand
verloren und Elektronen können in diesem
Zustand ohne Verluste geleitet werden.
Zum anderen stoßen diese Materialien Magnetfelder
ab - Magnetfeldlinien werden also um die Material
herum gelenkt.
Und das heißt im Klartext, dass Supraleiter
deswegen auf einem Magnetfeld schweben.
Möglich würden damit also viel einfacher
nicht nur Magnetschwebebahnen.
Mit Hilfe von supraleitenden Materialien,
die bei Raumtemperatur funktionieren, könnten
beispielsweise auch äußerst effiziente Quantencomputer
- und das in großer Menge - produziert werden.
Denn supraleitende Materialien sind wichtig
für die Konstruktion der Quantenbits, der
QBits.
Aber auch andere elektrische Geräte, die
sehr leistungsfähig sind, könnten mit Hilfe
dieser Technik optimiert werden.
Denn das Problem einer drohenden Überhitzung
könnte durch den Einsatz supraleitender Materialien
ausgeschlossen werden.
Den Stromleitungen ohne Widerstand werden
nicht warm.
Die Verluste in Stromleitungen könnten quasi
Richtung null gehen.
Und hier gibt es tatsächlich noch jede Menge
Einsparpotential.
In Deutschland gehen jedes Jahr 4 Prozent
des Stroms so verloren. das sind 24 Terawattstunden.
Das 24 Milliarden Kilowattstunden.
Eine riesige Menge.
Uns Verbraucher würde das mehr als 7 Milliarden
Euro kosten.
Und schon heute werden Supraleiter eingesetzt:
beispielsweise in der Magnetresonanztomographie
oder in Teilchenbeschleunigern.
Doch bislang müssen sie enorm aufwändig
gekühlt werden, denn ihren elektrischen Widerstand
verlieren sie erst bei sehr kalten Temperaturen
ziemliche nahe dem absoluten Nullpunkt von
-273,15 Grad Celsius.
Dazu der US-Physiker Ranga Dias: “Die Kosten,
um diese Materialien so kalt zu halten, sind
so hoch, dass man ihr volles Potenzial bislang
nicht ausschöpfen kann“.
Supraleitung bei Raumtemperaturen könnte
also viele der großen Probleme unserer Zeit
lösen.
Weniger Treibhausgase, weniger Kraftwerke
und niedrigere Kosten!
Die großen Fragen also lauten: Wie muss ein
Material gestaltet sein, dass es auch bei
Raumtemperaturen Strom verlustfrei leitet?
Wie müssen die Atome in solch einem Supraleiter
angeordnet sein?!
Trotz intensiver Forschung zerbrechen sich
Physik-Teams über dieses Rätsel schon seit
mehreren Jahren den Kopf.
Uns so ist Supraleitung bisher also nur unter
bestimmten Umständen möglich - beispielsweise
bei sehr tiefen Temperaturen.
Damit Supraleiter funktionieren, müssen sie
mindestens auf minus 200 Grad gekühlt werden
- so Stand jetzt.
Und das ist schon der bisherige absolute Rekord.
Doch das gehört jetzt der Vergangenheit an.
Dazu der US-Physiker Ranga Dias, der an der
aktuellen Entwicklung beteiligt war: “Einen
Supraleiter zu entdecken, der bei Raumtemperatur
funktioniert, ist so etwas wie der heilige
Gral der Festkörperphysik.
Es ist ein Problem, das über 100 Jahre alt
ist.
Manchmal haben wir schon gedacht: Oh, das
ist ja gar nicht möglich.
In diesem Sinne ist es eine fundamentale Entdeckung.“
Das bestätigt auch sein Physiker-Kollege
Chris Pickard, der die neue Entdeckung aus
den USA auf der Nachrichtenseite des Fachmagazins
“Science” als ZITAT “Meilenstein”
beschreibt.
Und so konnten auch die beteiligten Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler ihren Augen kaum glauben,
als sie die Messkurve das erste Mal genauer
in Augenschein nahmen.
Denn der elektrische Widerstand ihrer Probe
war plötzlich auf Null gesunken.
Und genau DAS ist das typische Charakteristikum
eines Supraleiters!
Doch anders als in bei den bisherigen wissenschaftlichen
Experimenten in diesem Bereich, fand das Experiment
von Ranga Dias und seinem Team praktisch bei
Raumtemperatur statt!
Hier waren also keineswegs extreme Temperaturen
von mindestens minus 200 Grad Celsius notwendig,
damit der Supraleiter funktionierte.
Die Temperatur bei diesem Experiment lag stattdessen
bei stolzen (plus) 15 Grad Celsius.
Und genau das schien bislang unerreichbar!
Die Entdeckung ist also ein großer Fortschritt.
Das zeigt auch die Geschichte der langen Suche
nach einem Supraleiter, der bei Raumtemperatur
funktioniert.
Ein Rätsel, das vor allem die Physikerinnen
und Physiker im Bereich der Festkörper schon
seit fast 100 Jahren beschäftigt.
Denn bereits 1911 hatte ein holländischer
Wissenschaftler entdeckt, dass Quecksilber
seinen Widerstand verlor, als er es mit Hilfe
von flüssigem Helium bis auf minus 269 Grad
heruntergekühlt hatte.
Es dauerte rund 50 Jahre, bis die Fachwelt
diese Beobachtung erklären konnte.
Demnach liegt der verlustfreie Stromfluss
an der Paarung von Elektronen.
Diese überwinden am absoluten Temperatur-Nullpunkt
bei minus 273 Grad Celsius ihre gegenseitige
elektrostatische Abstoßung.
Somit wandern sie dann paarweise und reibungsfrei
durch das Kristallgitter.
Später konnte die Supraleitung dann auch
bei anderen Metallen aufgespürt werden.
Die nächste größere Entdeckung erfolgte
dann vor 34 Jahren (1986) durch Forschungsteams
von IBM.
Die Fachleute hatten erstmals einen nichtmetallischen
keramischen Supraleiter aufgespürt.
Seine Sprungtemperatur liegt bei minus 238
Grad.
Die Jagd nach immer wärmeren Supraleitern
ging somit in die heiße Phase!
Vor 19 Jahren (2001) hatten Fachleute dann
Magnesiumdiborid genauer ins Visier genommen.
Seitdem weiß man, dass sich diese einfache
Verbindung wie ein klassischer Supraleiter
verhält.
Konkret bedeutet das, dass Magnesiumdiborid
bereits bei minus 234 Grad vom normal-leitenden
in den supraleitenden Zustand wechselt.
Klar ist dennoch auch: Der genaue Mechanismus,
der hinter der Hochtemperatur-Supraleitung
steckt, ist bisher noch weitgehend unklar.
Hohe Sprungtemperaturen aber sind doch möglich,
wie Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vom Max-Planck-Institut für Chemie aus Mainz
vor sechs Jahren (2014) erstmals bewiesen
hatten.
Sie hatten eine Schwefelwasserstoffverbindung
bei minus 70 Grad zum Supraleiter gemacht.
Das Geheimnis dahinter: Ein extrem hoher Druck.
Notwendig war hier ein Druck von 2,5 Megabar.
Die Fachleute gehen davon aus, dass dieser
hohe Druck die wasserstoffreichen Verbindungen
in einen metallischen Zustand bringen.
Im vergangenen Jahr gab es dann eine weitere
Erfolgsmeldung vom Team des Max-Planck-Instituts
für Chemie in Mainz.
Die Fachleute um den Wissenschaftler Mikhail
Eremets hatten den Rekord für die Hochtemperatursupraleitung
bei minus 70 Grad Celsius geknackt.
Dafür hatten sie Lanthanhydrid synthetisiert,
das unter sehr hohem Druck sogar schon bei
minus 23 Grad Celsius seinen elektrischen
Widerstand verliert.
Die Proben wurden in einer nur einigen hundert
Kubikmikrometer kleinen Kammer einem Druck
von 1,7 Megabar ausgesetzt.
Das entspricht dem 1,7 millionenfachen des
Atmosphärendrucks.
Dann kühlten die Fachleute die Probe ab.
Und tatsächlich: Bei einer Temperatur von
minus 23 Grad Celsius sank der elektrische
Widerstand des Materials auf Null.
Um wirklich auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, dass
es sich tatsächlich um Supraleitung handelt,
wurden zudem auch Messungen in einem äußeren
Magnetfeld durchgeführt.
Denn diese stören die Supraleitung: Der Übergang
verschiebt sich durch den Einfluss eines Magnetfeldes
zu niedrigeren Temperaturen.
Und genau das war in diesem Experiment der
Fall.
Der Mainzer Forscher Mikhail Eremets bezeichnet
die neue Entdeckung aus den USA übrigens
als großen Fortschritt.
Die amerikanischen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hatten das in Mainz entwickelte Material tatsächlich
auf gut Glück durch Kohlenstoff ergänzt.
Enthalten sind außerdem auch Wasserstoff
und Schwefel.
Diese Stoffkombination platzierte das US-Forschungsteam
dann zwischen zwei feine Spitzen aus Diamant.
Zudem wurde grünes Laserlicht eingesetzt,
um die Reaktion anzuregen.
In die Hochdruckkammer ließen die Fachleute
dann Wasserstoffgas einströmen.
So kam es zu einer chemischen Reaktion, bei
der sich Schwefelwasserstoff und Methan bildeten.
Über die Diamantspitzen konnten die Forscherinnen
und Forscher den Druck auf die Probe immer
weiter erhöhen, da die Diamanten selbst wie
Ambosse wirken.
In einem ersten Schritt bildete sich zunächst
ein flüssiges Gemisch, das nach und nach
fester wurde.
Unterhalb von 40.000 Bar formte sich dann
ein Kristall.
Doch die Fachleute machten weiter und pressten
die Diamanten immer weiter zusammen.
Zudem fuhren sie die Temperatur immer weiter
runter.
Die Überraschung war groß!
Denn der Gefrierpunkt musste in diesem Experiment
nicht einmal unterschritten werden.
Bereits bei einer Temperatur von (plus) 15
Grad Celsius wurde die Probe supraleitend.
Der Druck hierbei: 2,7 Millionen Bar.
Ein irrsinniger Wert, der in der Praxis so
nicht erreicht werden kann.
Weitere Experimente bestätigten dann, dass
es sich tatsächlich um den supraleitenden
Phasenzustand handelt.
Zum einen konnte dies auch hier wieder mit
Hilfe eines von außen angelegten Magnetfeld
demonstriert werden.
Zum anderen fiel der elektrische Widerstand
von jetzt auf gleich auf den Wert null.
Auch das ist ein typisches Merkmal eines Supraleiters.
Nach Ansicht der Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler ist dieser Weltrekord wohl
vor allem auf de kristalline Struktur des
Methan-Schwefelwasserstoff-Gemisches zurückzuführen.
Methan und Schwefelwasserstoff könnten möglicherweise
immer abwechselnd feste Gitterplätze im Kristall
besetzen.
In den Zwischenräumen dagegen sind möglicherweise
Wasserstoffatome eingelagert.
Spektroskopische Analysen lassen darauf schließen,
dennoch sind auch andere Kristallstrukturen
denkbar.
Wie man sich den Kristallaufbau genau vorstellen
kann, wollen die Physikerinnen und Physiker
jetzt in der kommenden Zeit untersuchen.
Eine enorm wichtige Forschungsfrage.
Denn Erkenntnisse in diesem Bereich könnte
uns bei der Suche nach Raumtemperatur-Supraleitern,
die sogar bei geringem Druck ihren Widerstand
verlieren, nach vorne bringen.
Mit diesen neuen Erkenntnissen aus den USA
ist der Heilige Gral der Festkörperphysik
also noch nicht ganz gefunden.
Denn das wäre ein supraleitendes Material,
das nicht nur bei Raumtemperatur funktioniert,
sondern auch unter geringerem Druck.
Dennoch: Auch diese Entdeckung der ersten
Supraleitung bei Raumtemperatur ist eine entscheidender
Meilenstein.
Das sagt auch das US-Forschungsteams selbst:
“Wegen der Notwendigkeit einer Kühlung
konnten Supraleiter-Materialien die Welt bisher
nicht in dem Maße transformieren, wie es
sich viele vorgestellt haben.
Aber unsere Entdeckung reißt nun diese Barrieren
ein und öffnet die Tür zu vielen neuen potenziellen
Anwendungen.“
Dennoch gibt es noch viel zu tun, um auch
praktische Anwendungen zu ermöglichen.
Dafür muss vor allem der Druck, der benötigt
wird, deutlich verringert werden.
Das US-Forschungsteam ist optimistisch, dass
dies gelingen kann.
Dazu schreibt das Autorenteam in seiner aktuellen
Studie: “Ein chemisches Tuning unseres Dreiersystems
könnte die Eigenschaften der Raumtemperatur-Supraleitung
bei geringerem Druck erhalten“.
Und in diesem Video “Hochtemperaturrekord:
Supraleitung bei Raumtemperatur?”
da geht es um den letzten Rekord 2019.
Auch der war schon bahnbrechend.
Also anklicken, anschauen und abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!